bravo alors qu'ils me donnent des scoops
voilà ce qui motive qui m'apprend des
choses c'est un vrai on devrait proposer
mission à bien bravo 4è vous les blues
ont comme moi donc ça fait plaisir
jeudi dernier on assiste à un clash en
rafale je pense que vous rappelez la
licorne s'était benjamin castaldi le pot
alors qu'ils n'avaient rien demandé mais
benji s'est retrouvé pris dans un
engrenage entre cyril jean-michel et
mathieu non c'est si vous êtes en vain
de parler de régime de stomy bugzy
mincir il ouvre le bal sur benji et tous
ne s'engouffre dans la brèche
c'est une nouvelle baba ali je me
rappelais plus haut si vous avez
beaucoup narcissique ou drôle non
j'imagine oui ça pour le port pour la
pour la pièce ces tirailleurs et les
jeter en prison bien des flandres stalag
au début et non je m'installe dit il
serait pas crédible à 6,6
il faut qu'il fasse encore deux semaines
de comme jamais alors benjamin castaldi
et aux éclats sur cette valve ne sont
pas trop me déteste que les autres
chroniqueurs l'ovale écoutez bien ce que
va glissé jean michel et surtout
regardez la réaction de benjamin il va
pas qui fait du tout qu'il fasse encore
deux semaines
comme j'aime
un second de la joie à la haine regardez
comment ils se retournent vers jean
michel et le couple pression qui va lui
m sauf que la rafale va continuer puis
enfin dans le bouquet final du patro
déjà maintenant la cassette a dit là
c'est pas comme je sais comme j'aime
beaucoup ce pauvre
et malté magnifique jury toi tu es bien
comme ça toi à toi tu es bien avec un
corps importants et des yeux petit vieux
corps important c'est comme ça que tu
aimes tu serais beauchemin ce temps ici
un très bel homme me prévaloir il un
succès kms de voies carpani ah oui je
vous dis ah oui non mais sa femme être
content de l'apprendre
oui le seul bon côtoie un petit peu là
là même la même clinique et c'est vrai
qu'il a beaucoup de succès par une
arrivée toutes les filles et les femmes
m'ont demandé comment il allait s qui
fait dans la clinique mais xivè une
clinique baillis essaie de se faire
ouvrir les yeux et pas compris encore
ben oui non mais non mais c'est vrai
quand il fait beaucoup de choses dans la
clinique se dit là bas il prend soin de
lui pas très bien transpole si je peux
me permettre
il refait pas faire tout son corps comme
on pense il fait beaucoup de soin du
visage personnes arrêtées des massages
vous avez fait un geste et non pas du
tout j'ai fait je fais de l'hydra
l'hydratation
il aura passé à face yalta dire à hydra
faciale sertic hydrate bien la peau et
une pique qui ont laissé poindre les
hommes c'est une fois par mois ces
attaques infondées at ap ap le lead ryan
jaffe d'hydra faciale
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais voulu mais m j'y croyais pas tu
croyais pas en tout cas ça vous va très
bien les draps faciale merci à mr
vraiment vraiment je vous le dis
continuez l'inra faciale pensée de
chaque soir depuis dix ans vous donnez
votre avis sur la télé on va dire qu'en
ce moment vous vous lâchez tellement que
j'aurais de quoi faire une tare baba
spécial télé mais tout ça ça vous a
donné l'idée de faire un nouveau one man
show ah oui oui un nouveau one man show
vous savez ce qu'il s'est vraiment passé
les infos par rapport à lui vous
démontrez les travers de la télévision
avec des sketches sans concession un
portrait de la télé au vitriol sur un
ton décalé la lourdeur oui ça va
s'appeler cyril hanouna allume la télé
et voici la bande annonce exclusive dont
cyril hanouna allume la télé quand il
parle de france télévisions cyril n'y va
pas avec le dos de la cuillère alors
j'allais mais ma télé on jure que c'est
vrai et j'ai demandé aux gens qui
étaient autour de moi on est bien en
2020 on n'est pas dans 82 cyril hanouna
allume la télé ce sont des jeux de mots
désopilant oui par parler du retour d'un
termine quand c'est plus d'indiens cette
phrase alors j'allais mais ma télé cyril
hanouna allume la télé c'est une
écriture aiguisé et un sens de la mesure
pas sur quelle chaîne cette merde
[Musique]
alors j'allais mais ma télé celle d'anna
allume la télé c'est aussi analyser les
audiences sur un ton décalé caustique et
tout en nuances france 2 j'adore les
grosses têtes à la radio et en télé faut
combattre ça ne marche pas j'ai toujours
des audiences de merde alors j'allais
mais ma télé et de clous du spectacle
quand cyril hanouna parle de son amour
pour les série américaine hawaii five o
je vais pas mais parce que c'est une
connerie 0 d'ailleurs aimé ça marche pas
ça non plus c'est de la merde en boite
c'est de la merde en boite c'est la
nonna allume la télé prochainement en
tournée dans tous les bars à chicha de
ceux ci ont brillé et cela m'a tuer bad
ragaz d'aniche décembre qu'est ce qu'il
ya mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas besoin
de faire un spectacle vous dites en
direct ce que vous pensez donc c'est
vrai la bamba triste pour ce faire
autant d'amis quand même hein quoi on
est triste pour ce faire autant d'amis
que vous avez défoncer tout le monde
mais je défonce mes propres émissions
j'ai encore mes consignes argent je
pense à il est comme ça de naissance
quand ça marche pas je pars défoncé mais
des missions et quand on a fait des
merdes que je l' ai toujours dit les
cover vous avez dit oui mais même nom
mais merde j'avais marché dernièrement
j'ai dit yannick on a fait des additions
pour y mourir
je les ai vus au strike c'était pas pour
y installer le paris handball a ouvert à
tous il adore le vendredi à voile atp
people aussi
moi j'avoue voilà que ça méritait encore
mué en doutes ira très bien
isabelle morini-bosc eric doses répétées
fort sa marque et sa baignade jusqu'à
répète tout le temps yahia il ya cinq
choses qui avaient peut être tout le
temps en fait moi c'est sûr fait
isabelle morini-bosc c'est comme les
poupées qu'on achète en fait à cinq
phrases et tu choisis mais c'est ça
qu'on aime et qui me rappelle toujours
que c'est vrai vous avez raison mais
aussi son lourd ohlala alors je n'en ai
pas c'est vrai ce n'est pas sa stupeur
ça c'est une info médias merci on vous
avez drame qui verra dans
répète tout le temps son midi que le
congé du comestible mais ça tout le
monde le sait est autre chose qu elle
dit tout le temps c'est moi aussi ouais
moi aussi moi aussi voici c'est moi
aussi et à chaque fois qu'un chroniqueur
dit quelque chose toujours quelle liste
moi aussi parce qu'isabelle a besoin
d'amour alors peut t'aider à l'oreille
pour entendre la voix au loin qui dit
tout le temps moi aussi c'est un premier
épisode de madame moi aussi quand ça
parle de sa relation privilégiée avec
château isabelle est jalouse et objet de
rappeler son existence
on est on est pareil on est balance tous
les deux l'aîné pratiquons le même jour
à 10 jours fatou et moi oui mais nous on
est en crise et une qualif et des
compléments patrick sébastien isabelle
ne peut résister à l'envié de réagir
immédiatement
c'est ce que j'adore patrick sébastien
c'est quand même dommage non mais c'est
pas et je peux finir ma phrase si tu
permets en fait à chaque fois quelques
points d'apport dans l'émission on
entend toujours cette même voie c'est
même au loin j'ai tout figaro je peux
renier bon je me suis fait engueuler je
sais que ça ça vous intéresse à mort
raymond et gilles tout ça ils sont comme
des fous sur ce qu'on raconte qu'elle a
passé un week-end très chaud d'isabey ne
peut pas s'empêcher de répéter moi aussi
jusqu'à ce qu'elle ait la preuve que
tout le monde s'en fout j'irai vis d'eux
m'a dit vous avez vu une énorme que ce
week-end quoi des 25 mètres alors vous
allez nous en parler dans un incroyable
je vois ça géraldine maillet qu'est ce
cas là elle a vu une énorme que ce week
end à parler dans un instant vous aviez
déjà mais tu sais rien de sérieux si un
c'est rien de grave
quand je dis ça explique pourquoi benji
son chroniqueur préféré qu'isabelle
ressort encore son fameux moi aussi un
cyril mais vous craquer complètement la
boule tiédeur il vous répond il peut
vous aider que ça c'est vraiment
quelqu'un de très sain qu'on a parlé de
vous lui at il aucun dégât
[Musique]
mais attention on peut lui dire elle
changera jamais on l'a où la garde comme
ça et on l aime comme ça mine de rien
c'est vrai franchement voilà si elle
change et ça serait plus isabelle est
bien sûr non j'adore mon tir voilà tant
qu est ce qu a dit non non vous les
nîmois caméra le nouveau copain c'est
clément guérin
en fait la banque par le calme marquée
selon elle par planus a vu que les
membres où tu es tellement tu es content
d'avoir aidé est très copain avec
isabelle jeu l'adorent hommage ensemble
ce soir en plus qua non maison bollinger
ensemble la semaine dernière et ouais
est-ce qu'il va pas devenir président de
la république celui-là non mais c'est
vrai hein parce qu'il ya des similitudes
non mais vraiment intérêt à regarder
bayadh y des cartonnages l'écart d'âge
vous avez quel âge 22-20 quoi ça veut
dire vous avez cinq fois votre 1ère fois
non pas en décalant pas du tout novice
vous dînez encore avec eux clément oui
oui ce soir à 18 heures salle et rires
moi aussi mais parce qu'ils ont dîné
ensemble la semaine dernière avec les
mots mais qu'est ce qui vous a raconté à
me des choses passionnantes genre quoi
la guerre bah ça se voit que tu te
souviens c'est quoi la guerre la guerre
des tranchées des choses confidentielles
peuvent pas être divulgués à l'annonceur
et qu'est ce que vous lui a raconté
vous avez dit quoi les histoires drôles
de tous voilà où il a parlé de grosse
rigolade tiens c'est vrai on a dit qu'on
n'y croyait pas du tout au début mais en
fait c'était génial
ouais avait l'air sympa ce repas les
fans ont mélangé les images télés des
images de mes films préférés
alors je dis c'est de faire une nouvelle
séquence cyril est un mot que vous
répétez tout le temps à votre avis c'est
lequel ge pas le mot visite le plus haut
dans l'émission ces couches je vais vous
dire non c'est un frère frérot alors
j'ai pris au moment où vous répétez 12
fois ce mot en moins d'une minute et je
les mènerai qu'une séquence culte du
cinéma français s'appelle touche pas à
mon cinoche on s'efforce efforts il crée
ce match la craie tout le temps ça
cogite
et s'ils changent en fait
alors quand il fait un monologue sur la
gourmandise de françois hollande c'est
un festival deux frères et deux frérots
c'est un peu saoul et les voisins on à
l'elysée premier truc qu'il a visités si
les cuisines notre itinéraire basse il a
des moyens qu alger - ici - sandwich
aubry féraud et même moi tout de suite
un tiramisu g raccompagné l'auto perron
frère c'est qu'à une chose c'est est-ce
des mots c'est pas possible d'entendre
ça tout cas nous servir
c'est le mec a fait le plus fort ou ses
amis sa ligne je veux faire un petit
room service avant et tu restes et
connell sur la vie de ma mère certes il
est arrivé là bas il a pris 25 kg en 154
il a dîné coût total frères lumière pour
finir le mercredi c'est que tu as eu ma
chronique avec la révolte des chroniques
qu elle adore canton celui qui les
paient grassement ou plus légèrement
pour d'autres c'est bien sûr le moment
de quoi je parle pas de moi on est sur
un jeu sort du bac la libaba clash
normalement ils ont aussi un enquête
enquête sous haute tension avec des oufs
des milliardaires ils prennent des
voitures il s'est dit paul les
milliardaires complètement des offres à
ça ça m'a juste de passer avec sa bête
noire
j'ai peu de temps
connard vous choquer bernard manque à
bernis n'ont pas choqué mais c'est avéré
c'est quelque chose vous pardon vous
avez déjà ferro s'avachir les oreilles
la lecture ça va bien
j'suis pas content c'est pas pourquoi m
mais bon quoi je suis fière mais comme
beaucoup à faire et a complètement loupé
[Musique]
le regard et la voix qu'après la boj
l'épousé oui la loi tepa boni riche
n'est célèbre est-ce que vous rentrez
facilement il vaut mieux être au top
jaune est au top après par exemple vous
allez faire un achat dans un tgv en
étant connecté au réseau public
on peut récupérer vos données bancaires
on peut récupérer tout ce que voulait
tant la masia le petit caleb le ctps cdd
dans son jet privé on peut aussi de pira
benhalima oui c'est vous êtes toujours
être pas tort oui chef
est-ce que vous lâche auriez patoche
pour moi même temps rêve ça fait mal
6 heures
[Applaudissements]